yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is the hourly super blitz arena on
DHS I'm a little bit late but maybe I
can catch up what is that like a channel
when I have I'm nine minutes late so not
ideal but it's what it is so II through
unite against mine try at a bank Oh huh
okay I think I can go be six here come
with this yeah white is just developing
very naturally here with b3 we should be
too yeah white can never be worse in
such a situation it's a little bit I
named Bish's but it's definitely not bad
okay I go d5 claiming that it doesn't
even go for it okay I was thinking he
would go with hanging pawns would see
forward didn't do that okay
yeah it's let's get rid over this night
dem only five it's a bit of an annoyance
okay
does not really react to this okay so
I'm taking yeah I wonder if I take it
twice my bishop is not really great yeah
I'm thinking d4 but it could be that
could be a little bit on its own this
pawn okay oh I have to consider this
little but I would like to trade off my
Bishop on b7 em that looks a little bit
odd this place why does playing this way
Liam very playing quickly but in a
strong way I don't see how I can get rid
of my bishop here I'll stop in g4 for
the moment yeah White has some many easy
moves is the problem it's very easy to
play and I don't have anything really
wow that's awful absolutely awful
position
yeah I've almost lost you I think I know
that looks extremely wacky but maybe it
irritates them get the King out of them
and I had to speed up anyhow he's
playing in sandals understandably and
the position is pretty off of a meme
okay try to go to be AIDS it's a bit odd
I mean why it is still a lot better of
course but okay yeah I have rook h8 yes
30 seconds now the problem is it's not
like he's playing quickly and has good
chances to win on time but um the white
is also just better it's a problem it's
not like he's pushing some bad position
on time no wow what is what a
fantastically bad game on my enemy
yeah cannot even stop b7 here Wow okay
that guy just blitz out every movement
killed me great what happens
I somehow drifted into a really terrible
position there hmm okay that will be
tough him it will be tough to get into
some sort of contention in this tone
yeah pretty high rated opponent okay
that's a good opening position for white
oh it gets better
I rather take this than the exchange
it's it's a super-important sent upon e
seven it seems that I was a good
decision I have some discoveries but the
check is also very strong and now I'm
making G 897 made even and this wins the
night okay so maybe this should be quick
win
would be nice if he actually resigned
but doesn't seem to be the case
I came I'm still the first game what the
heck come on give me a game it's always
a bit unnerving if you have those late
joins and then I mean it's kind of
tricky anyway to get back into it but
then you don't don't get any air don't
get a pairing
buzzer King here's always a bit tricky
for me I'm not so quick but 16 something
rating yeah there's scotch four nights
and going to go for them main line like
it's taking a lot of time if they are
very slow and basically turned it into a
bullet game that's of course nice yeah
it's still main line theorem
why develop see with queen III Bishop f4
and Braga's playing although
theoretically recommended moves
b3 is anticipating a possible route
could be aid and prepare C form to check
out the black pawn structure this is
what I just did
the the reason why why it is not much
but a little bit more comfortable in
these positions is that the pawn
structure is slightly slightly superior
black has free porn islands I only have
two the d5 pawn is a little bit weak now
and it's interesting my knight is
putting some pressure on their pawns -
you could imagine that it is better on
deform trying to jump into f5 I think
I'm going for ice he's got d4 now I did
not see that Ruby 7 was actually
covering the bishop I mean it's not
difficult to see what I have to be
somewhat quick so he just gave me gave
me that pawn um young f3 is more
desirable to blunt this bishop I have to
watch out for Bishop Jake's f3 though
[Music]
okay
it seems he wants to get denied in jf4
oh I can I didn't see that one coming so
only thinking about f1
yeah this is very comfortable though
I need to unpin this of course a 95 out
of 1:00 even more stuff but okay not a
big problem and she resigned okay that
worked out well
oh it's a little bit tricky at the
buzzer King for me so five points again
again a buzzer King opportunity usually
if I do this I'm going to claim my
absolute main lines even though you
could argue that should play more
sharply to to make quicker winners
possible but for me it's important that
I have some easy moves and I rather play
my normal stuff I wonder if he's got f4
here maybe he has I can take plane ith
500 that cannot be good
that looks very weak g3
white looks uncoordinated c2 is hanging
it's not easy to cover actually 93 I'm
going to snatch and then that's not
pretty move not necessary 9 takes it to
was a big folk here here we go oh and
this one I just got to check here it I
hope we should be six yeah that's the
Queen
okay so it was a good decision to
Berzerk that I'm going to lose that on
time ah
pick an ant begin the hunt only four
points anonymous five and I'm not going
to be zerk him we kind of already Louis
up to the top oh this is a funky line
and it's this is one of the things white
is a lot oh that's weird
Knight takes e4 is there the sharp move
it's actually excellent for white but
extremely murky so I always wonder if
somebody maybe it would play into it
like gambling yeah and I can knowing
that it is bad but it's tough to refute
it okay this is just yeah almost winning
so um what to do f4 c3
yeah maybe see three bolster the center
[Music]
how many pawns to a half feels like one
poor no top ones I'm two pawns up okay
f3 is a little bit it's a little bit out
of place here after Bishop b6 for
example u5 would hang my idea is a king
h 1f hope it should be three that would
be a very very safe setup i wonder had
this is a diagonal why not let's look at
the c6 pawn
okay yeah no Knight c4 okay I don't know
Bishop a dream I could've played f5
maybe immediately it was just tempting
to to grab that tempo him
I'm also check oh okay
yeah I was attacking the the part of the
bishop and the Queen so a queen trade
was forced oh come on really
it's a full/queen okay
[Music]
a little bit pointless to continue in
case someone wouldn't know let's just
step out of this
[Music]
No yeah what I don't get it mean by
continuing he's them not able to score
points him and I completely understand
like playing on time or if it's like a
completely murky position but it's like
down everything and no particular hope
ok so the news oh I usually cancel and I
cannot discuss probably doesn't matter
all that much I get to know
yeah this is
oh this is one of the main lines in my
book actually I hope in a variation is
it's been a while yeah I have written
these parts like more than two years ago
and they have forgotten quite a bit it's
interesting hmm
yeah I cannot allow him to play a six
ready but here why does think is
probably better yeah okay they have to
go here for anyway no use and spending
time I cannot allow him to play a form
and block everything and then play g4
and stuff
Oh interesting okay ID five is such a
good square for my queen okay he's a
ticking Adam so yeah I will never show
g5 well rather g6 okay returning this is
not a bad idea
make g5 people go back and I don't don't
really see what I have okay let's do
this
hmm okay huh okay
I can check first Jim maybe yeah maybe
still going back tonight on b7s it's not
quite clear what it does it to be honest
wit I came I cannot win this that's
still quite tough
I can I could try to trip over like rook
g7 Queen e8 Queen g8 it's not easy for
white white either he's got this
extremely bad bishop wannabe - okay
mid okay so the tripling did work I'm
already on the first place hmm
interesting
by getting paired against the other
other guy Wow
Stonewall so let's play normal moves and
see what happens
yeah with colors reversed g5 is
extremely strong I just wonder if this
is the case here
the moves g4 as in reply irritates me
quite a bit
yeah it seems White has decided to
really be mean to a special bond Siwon
put everything on dark squares okay so
am I going to go I would like to play my
knight regroup the night like a knight
to e7 Queen b5 is very irritating though
a6 is slow yeah but maybe I can afford
that
Jim yes see for the problem with c4 is
it is it is such a it closes everything
yeah but I don't know opening it up it's
probably untimely so I have to do it
like that
so we gave me that porn that was nice
okay looking at the Jeep on okay so he
actually opens it up a little bit and
one day if I go do aegyo Queen g5 or a
25 I mean still not so easy to open the
position is really not so easy you know
it's easy okay it was friendly because I
mean how I wasn't sure how to open it up
so so easily
and now the app everything's opened up
Jim give me five is just
I'm just saying okay so how'd you do it
good night over to g5 maybe
to watch out for potential sacrifices
but okay I can actually go back to f5
next year if I like 25 is a queen Trajan
yeah not sure about you want to but it
makes this a little bit simpler problem
I Scott Bishop c5 coming okay
damn instant still have to do some work
here yeah this our list yeah just just
slow it's a bit it was a little bit of a
pain and blue to do such a game that I
was a bit too slow maybe I shouldn't
have given up this exchange thing I mean
okay it's probably a little bit too lame
because the game was such a such a
one-sided affair and sometimes and just
too too slow because you feel okay is so
one-sided you will win anyway innit
well sometimes you don't okay so now
opens the saw in here and I'm going to
going to go for the throat black simply
did not develop so we'll see how this
turns out okay 9f5 is an idea or simply
my queen f3 or something let's do this
97 I was more concerned about dad okay
I also take the g-seven him okay
take one g7 or why not I can take on f7
now threatening 96
not exactly easy to play for black
yeah Bishop f5 is probably going to win
yeah
guess so
chick is there anything better
I have no major
I think this is stronger Bishop g5 route
67
oh no check no chick yeah okay
apartments let's just grip all this
I'm really not lucky with my opponents
continuing this kind of things okay I
really want this Mandrake guy again that
won against me on time after playing
them well I'm not going to say it yeah
this is not really good for black people
to say the least
g6 only moves and then I play Bishop c4
one of the good lines is also Queen f3
b3 b7 that also is more or less winning
but I always feel like in a blitz this
is so this carries more punch because of
things like this king f7 Queen e6 Queen
f7 checkmate yeah but what is he going
to do in attacking everything so it was
a nice quick win
give me Monterrey again please yeah
we're down to 13 it's it's close yeah
it's close I really shouldn't have lost
that game that I also broke my streak
with without this city loss that would
probably already be yeah almost an
almost save
tell me a moment yet sometimes I forget
forget things
oh I shouldn't have a lot of the trade
really not
I mean it's still okay nothing
particularly wrong about my position but
it wasn't wasn't best play for sure okay
he wants to go f4 here okay
still have a g4 but if he goes age three
is a bit of an annoyance yeah it really
is
okay I mean if he plays F for FY it also
weakens a bit so maybe this isn't a big
deal still have I should have somehow
should have prevented the trade of the
bishop
one of the strongest III preventing c4
page five is not doing much after the F
to admit yen goddamnit
ih was kind of silly I don't know what
you - they can just play a phony for now
that is going to be good for white
absolutely no question
this is of course very very commercial
to say the least but I wanted to get
some sort of activity at least
I would like to yeah it doesn't work we
should be seven I would like to do that
but and stuff like Knight g4 simply
doesn't doesn't work okay
might not work objectively but I have to
get something going
this threatens probably not much queen
queen h3 okay
hey it's just going to lose on time
[Music]
it was full-scale irritation mode didn't
work really Wow bad opening player I
played the opening bad layer in law in
Bishop h6 was a pretty terrible thing
give me Monterrey please I really want
want my points back take any other game
just just I hope to get some points okay
let's go play twits going form some
gambit line
what what kind of crap is that okay and
this is the kind of thing that always
kind of annoys me because when you know
it's not working it's just it's just not
going to work ever whether they still do
it yeah and yeah you might blunder
something or whatever um anyway so how
am I going to play it this one and that
you fire
Queen h5 oh my god yeah yeah there are
tricks then there are tricks okay maybe
I made a mistake already against this
rubbish crate
I don't see a move that's kind of kind
of irritating 95 is a big issue
beautiful em came
a g5 maybe I can still escape and they
just going to play whatever well taking
on b2 first was probably stronger
the b2 pond is very important that I
have VP 1 Queen at some point maybe
Queen g7 is that going to win maybe I
mean I have lots of extra material Queen
g7 I have to probably play be one Queen
I'm going to sell at the end to some
sort of wacky ending the AK 27 threatens
maybe we should be successful
I'm going to lose this this idiotic game
he just this is a total nonsense opening
and we're white is just a piece down for
absolutely nothing
fantastic fantastic really
and then all of a sudden needs to draw
help Bishop takes em no you okay - 22
minutes
[Music]
no no probably not got you get a full
game in
[Music]
I probably should have played somewhat
less technical opening this is the kind
of thing where you can no grind out an
ending but not win in two minutes
yeah that's a good position but 20
seconds left
yeah maybe I get second place I probably
don't deserve to win this thing the way
I played lost the stupid game on time
and then they give me a piece like for
nothing and I get into this lost
position it's kind of silly right him
Jim it's quite quite resigned about this
position but
yeah I don't know does it actually count
for something here for reaching or is
that just for for nothing basically this
game
you know again I don't know if this is
important
I would offer draw if it's really for
for nothing
I completely forgot about that anyway
yeah I think it was it was for Noah
anyway what did I actually actually does
so so so I won that after all but hmm
yeah it was a weird tournament a really
weird tournament can i I just want to
quickly check something
what is that yeah I have to go to the
game section this is the city game my
opponent sacrificed the house I mean I
cannot believe any of that that's just
complete nonsense right it is not
complete nonsense oh my god Knight c3 is
actually a movie yes God
just as we Adam probably this is not
okay this 3695 him crazy dad so that's
extremely crazy so really and they
that's the move run okay
96 what the engine now gives me it's not
a particularly substantial depth okay
long f6 really Wow
oh okay no clue what's going on
okay I hope you enjoyed the video who
thinks thanks for watching